[موسيقى]
في البدء يجب ان يفهم نحن ممتنون لحلفائنا
لكنهم يساعدون انفسهم ايضا حقيقه ان روسيا
لن تتوقف عند اوكرانيا وهذا امر جالي
للجميع اتضح هذا بعد ترهيبهم بالنووي وما
الى ذلك روسيا لن تتوقف في اوكرانيا او
روسيا ستتوقف على وجه التحديد عن طريق
اوكرانيا نحن نقدر الخيار الثاني لانه ليس
لدينا خيار لا نريد ان نكون ضحايا لكن ليس
لدينا خيار سنقاتل حتى النهايه ولذا فاننا
نقدم الخيار الثاني الحلفاء ادعمونا لانه
اولا وقبل كل شيء هذا ثمن شهيد بنسبه اليه
لان روسيا ستذهب ابعد من ذلك وستموت
قواتكم وشعوبكم وستقاتلون من اجل دوالكم
لا يمكنكم خلاف ذلك هذا ما اعتقده لذلك
السؤال المطروح ليس كم يمكنكم مساعدتنا
انما كم يمكنهم مساعده انفسهم
[موسيقى]
الاسلحه تصل الينا ابطاء مما كنا نتوقع
الحلفاء يقررون ما اذا كان هذا السلاح قد
يصل اليوم او غدا في بعض الاحيان تكون
هناك بعض المشكلات اللوجستيه لكنني اعرف
ان بعض القاده قلقون وهم يفعلون كل شيء
حتى ياتي الدعم الينا بشكل اسرع كل يوم
عندما تتباطؤ الاسلحه يتباطا النصر الامر
لا يتعلق فقط بالاسلحه انه يتعلق بالكثير
من الاشياء انهم جميعا يفهمون اننا نفقد
اشخاص وهذا ثمن بعيد
[موسيقى]